uh this is a continued executive session
on
all pending legislation that we have
before the committee
um and before we get going with the
procedures um i'd like it if everybody
could join me of allegiance
this is an electronic meeting and i have
some announcements that need to occur
um i need members using devices in the
room to mute
and turn them off so that there is no
feedback
the microphones in the room pick up
sound very well or at least that's what
they
tell us and we need to be careful about
having an entire
conversation
mine was muted but something happened so
okay
um
so there is a sign up sheet
on bills this is an executive session
today
so sign up sheets on bills that we have
considered from my understanding were
closed on 11 59 of the last day that we
had public hearings on them
eventually the 8th today is the 10th
as to today as chair of the house
election law committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 in the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee
and scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
the meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of this committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the boom electronic platform
and is public and the public has access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the june platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with households in rsa91a
and anyone who has a problem listening
or accessing this meeting should call
3600 or email hcs
ledge leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all those
that are taken during this meeting will
be done by rule paul vote and we're
going to start
by taking a bold call attendance
um and let people know if you're
attending remotely if anybody's in the
room
um it is my understanding that
representative murray joins us again
today welcome um and
it's the director called rome thank you
i
guess who she's covering for um today
i believe representative murray is
freitas
he's having trouble logging on both she
and kat
are having uh sandler are having
problems logging on
and i have sent just so everybody knows
i have recent
um links to both of them very recently
but i will keep
trying if there are other issues maybe
we can
communicate could you check to see
if they might have a different email for
cam to send the link to
if they're using their house election
law
email um there's a lot of traffic going
i did send representative sandlers to
her personal address and i don't have
another address for representative
fredes so if if
anyone knows one i'd be happy to do that
and if not let's have them call in
i you know everybody has made an effort
to make all these buildings
meetings that we have problems with the
member accessing we'll take a break so
we can get it figured out
all right you want to continue madam
chair i'm president
representative growing here
here in my home and my son's in another
room
thank you representative hamer i'm here
in my home in manchester with one other
family member
thank you representative hayward
representative lane
i'm here and i'm sorry i am alone in my
home office and on the phone with
representative mcdonald yeah presenter
mooney
here representative your head present
and
no one is in this room with me
representative
o'brien i'm here representative coyly
right she's having trouble right right
right represent sweeney yeah
representative trojan
here representative ward uh here in
portsmouth two family members in the
house
mark is here okay so
we're just going to kind of all right
i'm going to go through
the the plan for the day and if people
are still
having access issues we're going to
break for 15 minutes
to give people an opportunity to get
this
worked out this is um as far as
i know this is our they're going to be
an executive session on all remaining
that we have at this point in time and i
want to give everybody
the opportunity to be here everybody on
this committee has been terrific about
attendance
and i'm not going to let electronic
issues prevent
people from attending um today
we will be hearing
[Music]
in a slightly different order than is
noticed so if i'm going to go a little
slower so everybody can get things
ordered
we're going to do 98 and 327
first both of those have been continued
from
a previous uh noticed executive session
we're going to move to 531
535 538
554 429
362 508.
it is my understanding that as to those
bills
we have a couple of amendments that
representative growing has worked on
but the one i have been informed he
plans to
introduce is amendment zero
seven four three
with the is there with the date
of march night i have
asked that that email be resent
this morning because of the email issues
this committee is currently having on
trying to
find anything so
if you don't have it in hand
the recess if we don't have everybody
present we'll allow you an opportunity
to get
that amendment 7
4 3 h
i am not aware of any other amendments
for the bills i just
listed if somebody has an amendment on
those bills
let's take the great followers take the
opportunity of the break to work out
electronic issues to
get those amendments in and then
after we vote on the bills that i
mentioned before ending with house bill
this committee will be taking another
recess
um and i'll determine at that time how
long it will be
because it is my understanding that
while we have
in our possession as to sp43
amendment 0639
we have been sent amendment 0 6
3 each
it is my understanding that we also
receive some emails
from representative growing
with an amendment possibly he is not
planning on introducing those
and it's my understanding there is
another amendment
for sb 43 that is being
finalized right now and we will be
taking a break so that all committee
members
have an opportunity to review all the
amendments before we
reconvene to vote on our last two bills
which will be
sd2 and sb43
um so it is looks to me
like we are still missing representative
sandler
and representative treatise
is that correct it is all right we are
going to take a break
until 10 25
and we will be in recess until that
point in time and let's see if we can
get that straightened out representative
mirrorhead
um on a technical issue just during the
break
i i figured out how to create what's
called a rule that directs
the incoming flow about sb43 into a
special
email box where i can read them all
separately
um and if anyone is you know interested
in in that and lots of little uh
guidance i'm happy to try to walk you
through it
it then clears out your inbox um
automatically
will it deal with the emails that we've
already got
i'll have to work i'll work on that
madam chair i'll see if i can find
another rules for that
i think everybody would be interested in
that um
because i there is an ongoing issue in
my opinion that has existed since the
beginning of the session
as to email communication because the
substance of what we're doing has
changed so much um
i'm not sure that the new rule
which was adopted makes a lot of sense
and there needs to be some consideration
on how we handle this going forward
uh representative moorhead i know i and
many
members sitting here today will be
interested in
getting your hints
approximately
good morning representative friedas it's
good to see you
um we are just on a break right now
while we're addressing technical
difficulties you know is your sign in
and representative sandler sign in and
so that's why
it appears that not much is happening
right now but um
the plan is to come back at 10 25.
thank you for your assistance that's
very common
representative sandler we see you
perfect we're we were on a recess until
25 so we could um i had to bring in my
tech support
excellent excellent i'm so glad that you
are with us so we're going to
be back in just a few minutes now that
everybody
that chairman our video is on and we are
unmuted
two four six eight ten
natalie can you just give me the roll
call this and i just wanna
we're not doing an official workout all
right eric i'm hoping
can people hear me without turning this
people online hearing me
okay senator bourne says yes
um so i'm just going to run from names
and just say
yes um it's not an official roll call we
recess for the purposes of getting
everybody here and i want to make sure
we've got everybody here let's just
start
all right make it representative murray
here
representative gary here representative
cody
i can barely hear you if you said
freitas yes i am here but i cannot hear
you very well
she can't hear me at all can other
people online hear me
you're coming through loud and clear uh
on my computer madam chair
me too here fine too
freitas try looking at the volume on
your computer
and seeing if it's turned up all the way
i checked my volume it's on high i can't
i'll listen carefully but it's not good
if you don't hear what's going on um
say it and we'll make sure somebody says
something so we can
try to get you to hear it um
you're here right yeah yes sir
representative hamlet
yes okay representative hamer
yeah i'd like to see you can we here
today i'm here and alone
in my home office all right we can hear
you all right
uh mcdonald is here representative
mooney is here
is here representative sandler are you
here i am here
in my home office alone okay uh
representative sweeney is here trojan
representative
jordan here
he's here and representative is here all
right we've got everybody so thank you
everybody for
indulging me in having this recess
so we could make sure that we have
everybody in attendance
as i stated before today we are
executing bills we're going to start
with 3
20 excuse me 98 uh
and we're going to go through some bills
we're going to take a recess and then
we're going to come back
and do committee executive session and
discussion on
sb2 and sb43
so the first motion for executive
session this morning is
hb 98 this had a public hearing
on january 29th
we continued that because during session
there was some
discussion about possible amendment to
this bill which relates to moving the
primary date in june um
and does anybody have a motion
on that representative growing madam
chair i moved to amend hb 98 with
amendment
0743h
to speak to your amendment
representative
yes madam chair hb 98 has filed
proposes to move the new hampshire
primary from the second tuesday in
september
to the first tuesday in june and to move
the filing date for candidacy from the
first wednesday
in june to the first wednesday in march
at the hearing for
hb-98 concerned the voice that the first
tuesday in june
would interfere with the last weeks of
school particularly where schools are
used as voting locations
i researched the school calendars of 10
of the largest school districts in new
hampshire and found that the last day of
the school
was between the 11th and the 18th of
june
this amendment will move the primary
date to the fourth tuesday of june
which puts it outside of the school
calendars but still before most families
take their vacations
we also heard concern that the first
wednesday of march
was too early for the start of the
filing period
this amendment moves the filing period
to the fourth wednesday of april
this does shorten the filing time the
period of time between the filing period
and the primary
to two months but of course nothing
prevents a candidate
from starting the campaign before the
filing period begins
secretary of state already has the
authority in redistricting
years to move the filing period back in
the event that redistricting is not
finalized before the filing period
begins
this amendment adds language to give the
secretary of state
similar authority to move the primary
date in a redistricting year
if he has exercised his authority to
move violent day
i urge you to support this amendment
hb-98
thank you discussions about this primary
data
representative lane yes i was wondering
why we're not retaining
this bill the same way we retain the
other bills
regarding a change in the date because
we thought
there would be some more work done into
and to
i guess that's not particularly to the
amendment but to the overall bill
um i believe and i'm ready to speak to
it on the bill itself that this is a
very important change i think it is
a change that benefits both of the major
i think it benefits all parties because
it gives an opportunity
to coalesce behind a uh behind the
chosen candidate
uh in a period of more than the current
seven or eight weeks that we have
and this allows us to get this bill
before the senate
hopefully passed there and allows for
planning time that's needed
by the secretary of state to make the
adjustments
representative barry yeah i just want to
kind of answer representative lane's
question
a little more directly she asked why
we're doing
this one and not the other two so we
talked about
working on the movement primary date
this is the this is the vehicle
that we're working on so the amendment
that we have before us
is is is the work product of that it's
already it's already undergone
i think two or three compromises at this
point as representative gruen said
particularly around school dates and
trying to make sure that the filing
window
uh kind of matches up with our
legislative schedule to as best as we
can so i hope that answers your question
representative lane
so so i guess to put your response
another way the retentive retention
wasn't so much because you disagreed
with the concept
people who were proposing this believed
that this was the better vehicle to do
it
right could i have a follow-up
madam chair go ahead
um i'm curious because when we had bills
like this before us
uh in previous session uh many people
felt that june was
too early that we were still doing the
house's business
and to try and run a campaign and finish
up the house's business
was too much of a burden particularly
for essentially a volunteer position
so i'm i'm curious as to what the reason
is for that change in opinion
now
i'm not sure that everybody had that
opinion i think
and thank you representative for the
questions on the bill i'm also one of
the sponsors on the legislation
um as we've said we have two other
pieces of legislation that do move the
primary date
um i do not think it is asking too much
of the individuals running for the
legislature
to campaign for a june primary and then
a november general election
uh like many grand staters then they
would be able to go
um and take a little vacation in july
and august
when most granite staters aren't really
paying attention to politics
anyways and then we rush right back into
uh after labor day weekend
into september and october um in those
that first week of november for the
general election
um we're really not overwhelmingly
changing the the calendar
of when a campaign is going to be really
the crunch time for the campaign
is always the last two weeks before the
election that doesn't change
under this bill and i can't change under
any legislation because
that's just a practical component of
political campaigning
um the 45-day window really before the
election
um is usually the time when people are
campaigning i don't see any reason
why this bill would require anybody to
campaign more than 45 days out from the
primary
and then 45 days out from the general
election when they're the nominee
especially when they're running for
state legislative seats uh
that we all occupy but this bill will go
to great lengths to ensure that
candidates that are running for those
executive council seats
uh some of those more competitive state
senate seats the congressional seats the
senate seats
and the governor's seat i will have more
time to organize and build their
campaign than something that both
parties
are going to benefit from in the long
run
representative cody thank you madam
chair i guess
i have the same concerns that
representative lane has
especially considering that
um i just lost my audio can everybody
hear me
yes okay now it's back um
especially considering the fact that
historically we've
we've wanted to take a closer look at
some of these and we did that in the
past and so
i think what ought to happen here is
this bill ought to be retained
as the other ones were and we ought to
work on those and come out with a
unified position uh that
includes both the majority party and the
minority party as to where we go forward
if we can't do that
that's another question but i will be
opposing the
the motion in chief when it arises thank
you
representative uh it's just a
just to kind of explain one more thing
to her
i've had a lot of work on this bill
talking with state reps
and what i have to constantly remind
them is we are not the only ones on the
ballot
and you can't look at our primary
solely through the limbs of a state
representative i can't say you disregard
it
but there's other people on the ballot
there's governor u.s senate
congress county commissioners there's a
whole
executive council of state senate
there's a whole different campaigns on
the ballot and we are a volunteer
legislator we all make the same amount
of money
the reality is as a state rep the
overwhelming vast majority of state reps
do not undergo primaries that are
incumbents
um and it's it's actually in my opinion
it burdened us the least and the idea
that somehow as legislators we can't
simultaneously read legislation and
campaign or walking two guns at the same
time is
is a little little out there most other
states do this
and i recognize that most other states
don't have a volunteer legislator
and i'm sensitive to that but i think
the reality is this
does more good than bad and it is
already the result of multiple
compromises we've already moved it back
um multiple compromises from europe
yes just to make that clear all right
representative
yeah i would like to respond as well to
that
a very small uh
minority of state rep races have
primaries
and even on state senate races which are
a little more competitive
very few of them have primaries on the
other hand
every state senate race has an opponent
in the general election
and nearly all state rep races have an
opponent in the general election so
i think the advantage of this is that it
gives
the parties time to coalesce behind the
chosen candidates and
as far as campaigning the
the representatives and senators that
don't have a primary most likely are
going to start campaigning before the
june primary or if they are they're
going to start whether or not it's in
june or september
so i i think that for the house races
it's
not nearly as big of an issue because
such a small proportion of these races
for anybody else on the motion on the
floor is a motion to
amend representative lane i guess i
would just like to comment that
because our pay is a hundred dollars a
year
many of us also work either full-time or
part-time
and also the legislative schedule at
least this year has been
grueling and i suspect it will be next
year as well
and i just would humbly point out
that not all of us have the
time to campaign do legislative work
and try and continue in our full-time
jobs as well
and i think that's one of the reasons
why in the past
people had not liked this position
including um many you know
from both parties actually so i hear
what you're saying
i just raised the concern and i realized
that's not a question but i just i am
concerned about it
thank you any other comments on the
motion on the floor which is
a motion to amend amendment
2021 0 7 4 3
8 i'm not seeing any i'm going to ask
representative mcdonald yes
representative cruz o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes representative
barry
yes representative grump roman
representative kweily yes mark says yes
representative cody no
representative ward no
representative murray no
representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas oh
represent hamlet no
representative your head no madam chair
the amendment three 0743 a pass
committee
eleven to nine is there a motion
representative i move on to pass
madam chair on uh hb 98
is
we've already talked about i think we've
had significant discussion
on the body of the bill and the purpose
of the bill so i
thank you i
i'm going to support the bill
i think the bill as we know has other
chambers
to deal with i do think that it raises
more concerns for the state rep race
perhaps than it does for other races so
and we'll see end up
so nobody else has any
comments i'm going to ask her to call
the phone
excuse me the motion on the floor is uh
ought to pass as amended hp 98 amendment
number
representative mcdonald yes
representative
tom o'brien yes representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative trojan yes
representative perry yes representative
growing
yes representative coyly yes
yes representative cody no
representative ward no
representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no representative
no adam cheer yes
11 to nine 1898 as amended will go on
the calendar
with an 11 tonight vote and i'll be
together
of an army report the next bill that
we're considering this morning is hb
327 requiring that voter show
identification when personally
delivering access to ballots to town and
city clerks
this was continued from march
8. um this had to do with the actual
envelope
and uh what was going to happen when it
was delivered
is there a motion yes
it's not a chair i hope to retain this
bill
is there a second assembly thank you
representative hayward
representative homer i would like to
speak to your motion
yes i would thank you uh this bill
has some aspects of it that
need to be answered more fully one of
them is about
the the affidavit envelope being marked
i spoke to my own town
moderator yesterday and she's concerned
about the practical uh
reality of that and
not wanting to open the envelope
representative bergeron brought up some
interesting points that are worthy of
consideration about whether or not the
word
or should be used in place of the word
and
at the end of uh line four
in the middle of line four this just
needs to
be discussed more in the larger context
of
treating absentee ballot and in
pre-processing absolute balance
so i would like to take for those
reasons thank you
um the motion on the floor is to retain
hb327
is your discussion on the motion in the
room here
or
i'm not seeing anybody indicating they
wish to speak in motion so i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the world the
motion on the floor
is to retain hp 327.
representative mcdonald yes
representative foodham o'brien
yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative tarosian
yeah representative perry yes
representative growing yes
representative
yes clerk is yes representative cody
no representative ward
no representative murray
no
no representative lane
no representative freitas
no representative hamlet
no representative muirhead
yeah madam chair yes
oh i'm sorry who did i not
representative and i believe voted yes
i'm sorry
no i i said no you did oh
i thought we heard yes over here
did i did i was did the wrong word come
in i don't know i'm sorry
the connection between the little tiny
thought in my head and the noise that
comes out isn't always as strong as it
yes all right the next build that we're
talking about this morning is 531
this is relative to determining the
qualification of voters and establishing
provisional voter registration and
provisional ballots
uh this had a public hearing on march 8.
representative i'll make a motion
i make a motion retain house bill 531
sure um i believe there's some some
pieces of
the bill that are worthwhile and make a
lot of sense there are some
details that need to be worked out hence
the reason to retain it so we can work
out
some of the little things that need to
be
massaged if you will and hopefully bring
it out as an otp
later in the legislative season
thank you is there anybody else who
wishes to speak to the motion on the
floor which is to retain
i guess i have a question about uh what
what are the details that need to be
worked out and what are the parts of the
bill that
people think has merit or specifically
the previous speaker
thank you yeah so i i think
there's some common sense um parts of
the bill
the provisional voter registration in
battles
i mean you know we do voter id
uh the reality is that people carry ids
i know in the past we've heard that
there's problems
with people that don't have ids but the
numbers don't show that
so i think it's common sense thing we
heard we heard that there's
um some um
fair amount of numbers every year people
that
don't bother to ever produce
id or you know uh concrete proof that
they're
that they're resident where they're
voting so i just think it's you know
other states do this there are other
states that do this with
you're uh about the provisional value
right right yeah
yes so anyway
all right seeing none i'm going to ask
her to call the bold emotion on the
floor as hb531 and the motion is to
retain
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative kweily yes
clark is yes representative cody
no representative ward
no representative murray
no representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane
[Music]
no representative freitas
no representative hamlet
no representative your head
no adam chair
yes okay 11 to 9.
hb 531
will be retained the next bill we have
in front of us this morning for
consideration is
5 35 5 35 is relative to the qualified
murder affidavit
it had a public hearing on march
8th is there a motion on hb 535
representative ross
uh yes ma'am i'm sharing my move that we
retained
sorry our promotion is to retain is
there a second
with the integrity in our elections i
spoke about this at length before so i
won't go on right now
but ap 535 needs a little more work so
i would like to retain it
is there any further discussion
[Music]
yes jim i guess i'd like to know um what
yep i i have to i have to balance it
with with other
with other legislation working working
its way through the system right now
i don't know what that means because i
have to consider all
legislature
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the roll
the motion on the force to retain hp 535
representative mcdonald yeah
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative trojan yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative kweily yes
representative ward no
representative murray no
representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no
representative your head no
madam chair yes
eleven to nine hb
535 will be retained the vote is
11-9
is
is relative to the domicile residency
voter registration and investigation of
verification letters in relative to the
terms resident inhabited residency
residency
this bill had a public hearing on march
8th
is there a motion representative yes
madam chad
we find hospital 538 in expedition to
legislate
is there a second second it's been
seconded by
representative gary do you want to speak
to your mother
yes ma'am chair thank you uh this bill
before us would revert us back to
how state law was before house bill 1264
was passed and implemented in 2018. uh
that bill
underwent thorough review when it was
debated and passed
in 2018 and we have run several
elections in the state of new hampshire
under those provisions since then
uh without issue and increased integrity
in our elections
so i would recommend that we all find
this built in expedient to legislate
in order to ensure the most trust and
integrity in our state's elections
motion
representative mcdonald yes
representative
tom o'brien yes representative sweeney
yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative yes representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative yes
yes representative cody no
representative ward no
[Music]
representative murray can you welcome
you oh i'm sorry
no representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane
no representative freitas
no representative hamburg
the next build of course is hb
554 relative to temporary absence from
domicile promoting purposes
um is there a motion on hb
554 representative mooney yes madam
chairwoman i would move that house bill
554 be retained
this legislative year is there a second
yes i would uh there's a lot of credible
issues
certainly in this build certainly
warrants a much fuller discussion than
we've had the time to
so thus i would encourage my colleagues
on the committee to vote
to retain any further discussion
yes ma'am could i ask the previous
speaker what what the nature of the
discussion is and
what needs to be further determined
go ahead i'm sorry thank you uh thank
you for the question
i with regards to domicile it's an issue
and there are various sub issues that go
with it in new hampshire
and so i think a fuller discussion based
on
this content would be warranted
to fully flesh out the issue of domicile
representative your head i'm curious
what problem again i'm curious what
problem the bill is trying to solve or
what is the particular problem that the
word domicile is causing
if i can answer and sponsor the bill i
don't think for this particular bill
to it issues not only the domicile issue
but the temporary aspect of whatever may
be going on in the state
so i think that was what was being
trying to be addressed in regards to
this legislation
and further defining as to
what is needed to be connected to the
state for purposes
of election laws in 654
additionally i think these provisions
are part of
ongoing litigation that would go back
two sessions to the bills that frankly i
think
a previous bill was directly related to
that would be what was referred to back
then as
sb3 um and so
i think some of the changes to the
statutes that are directly affected by
sb3 might be premature pending a
decision but by retaining them it gives
us as a body and ability to work with
these provisions
if we receive the decision on that
litigation
so i think that was part of the reason
this bill is was put in and that was
part of the
retain there any further discussion
on hb554 the motion on the floor
is to retain i would
i would just like to point out that this
does go back to sp3 and i am coming to
the conclusion particularly after the
end of this meeting that the senate is
the real cause for
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative barry yes oops
representative trojan
yes representative growing yes
representative clayly yes clerk is yes
representative ward no
representative murray
representative murray no
thank you representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane
no representative freitas
no representative you can handle it
no representative your head
no adam champ yes
eleven to nine hb 554 the room to retain
us eleven tonight it will be
retained the next bill
to be considered by the committee this
morning is
hb 429 this is relative
relative to college or university
student voting it had a public hearing
on march 8 is there a motion yes ma'am
chairman i hope that hb
429 will be inexpedient to legislate
is there a second i second that matters
second invite
representative swinney would you like to
speak to your motion representative
yes madam chairman this bill deals
directly with college student voting
which is obviously
a massive conversation that we had
a couple of days ago i want to address a
couple of things to the committee
this has been a question in front of us
for a very long time
and there are some tough questions to
ask here how can someone be
an out of state student but not an out
of state builder
if college students do have the right to
vote in our universities
where they go in their dorms which the
court systems have
said in some way what about the college
students from new hampshire that go
to school out of state do they get to
file absentee ballots
in their hometown what about college
students in new hampshire
who go from one town and then move to
durham where should they vote
these are some tough questions that we
have to answer
hb 429 does not do a good job of
answering that
and that's why i'm moving it to as
inexperienced to legislate
it doesn't answer our questions is there
any further discussion representative
i i think i agree i i think that um
the status of being an in-state student
is one that's decided by
it applies only to people who are
claimed as dependents
by their parent and and it applies a
12-month durational residency
requirement to those parents so it asks
are the parents who are claiming this
dependent
people who have been working and paying
taxes in new hampshire over the previous
year
um the status of voting doesn't depend
on
you know doesn't depend in any way and
whether you've been claimed as a
dependent by your parents they're two
totally separate
totally disconnected statuses and to
make one dependent on the other
to really introduce a lot of confusion
and also i think court breaking the law
and breaking the constitution because
the constitution prohibits
the racial residency requirements of
more than um about well
certainly of a year that would prohibit
that and so do
the voting rights act thank you
representative moorhead i also thought
it was
i recognize that the university system
is technically independent so this bill
did not
have a fiscal note um but i thought
hearing that it might
cost uh potentially 170 million
to an institute of higher learning was
something that probably should have been
considered especially
given the current financial times
is there any further discussion on hb429
the motion on the floor is an expedient
to legislate
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative yes representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative quali yes
yes representative cody yes
representative ward yes
representative murray yes
representative sandler yes
representative hamer yes
yes thank you representative freitas
yes representative hamlet
yes representative
yes madam chair yes 20 to 0.
hb 429 has been unanimously
moved as being recommended to the house
courts in execution to legislate
there is no objection that will be going
on the consent council
the next bill that is before the new
hampshire house elections
committee this morning is hb
362 relative to the domicile of students
for voting purposes this matter had a
public hearing
on march 8th is there a motion
representative thank you madam chairman
i move that the committee
retained this bill hb 362.
representative mcdonald's second said
would you like to speak to your mother
yes i would thank you uh i don't think
this bill is ready to pass
there's two specifics about it one that
deletes rsa 654-1
section i which essentially defines and
have
inhabitants domicile for voting purposes
and it does this for repeals this which
applies to all voters i think that's
very
problematic secondly is my understanding
that
the the subject matter
this bill also touches upon matters
still
under litigation i believe related to
the form of sp3
reason i'd like to retain it is i think
that
due to other provisions in rsa 64 that
we
could remove the special status
of college students regarding uh
definition of navisal while still
fully protecting their rights to vote
in new hampshire if they are indeed
domiciled here thank you
thank you does anybody else wish to
i'm not seeing any so um i'm going to
call the rule
uh support to call the world the motion
on the floor is
each for hb 362 the motion is to retain
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative trojan yep
representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative quality yes clerk is yes
representative cody no
representative ward no
representative murray no
representative sandler no
representative hamer no representative
lane
now representative freitas
no representative hamlet
representative
oh sorry no thank you madam cheer
one to nine hb 508 will be
for me oh 362 i'm sorry i've got a
problem with my sheet
and my brain this morning the next bill
before
us is hb 508
this is establishing a committee to
study the definition of temporary as it
pertains
to residents in the state for voting
purposes
is there emotion representative
yes madam chair i moved in expedient to
legislation
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes very grateful madam chair uh this
is
a bill that i i would full heartedly
support and i appreciate what the
sponsor was
we have retained a bill previously today
uh that deals with the same issue and
that's where we should work on the issue
in this
committee especially given the the
dynamics of culvert
uh committee work would not be uh
applicable this year but private move it
out
is there any further discussion on the
motion representative
thank you in the spirit of limiting
committee activity this year um
[Music]
i'll vote to ito but i hope with the
other bill we retain we address these
issues because there's serious issues
and i think it's pretty unbelievable
that we we have an open-ended
term for temporary very very natural
where most people
think temporary is it's not five years
or ten years or
something or a long term like that so i
hope we address this
with the other bill because it is an
excuse me is itl
representative mcdonald yeah
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative fraley yes
representative ward yes
representative murray yes
representative sandler yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
senator hamlet yes
representative muirhead yes
all right hb 508 has been voted and
expedited to legislate by vote of
to zero if there's no objection that
will go on consent
calendar we have two items of business
left for this committee they are sp2
and sb 43 as i stated at the beginning
of the meeting we have a couple of
amendments
and it's my understanding there might be
another amendment
carefully let's begin our email
inbox um
we'd love to find it so
if we could take
it's my understanding that
representative lane and representative
mooney
are working on on something is that in
our inbox do we have something
no matter here i'm going to say no
because there are still some things that
need to be ironed out
so i'd like to make one more go through
with ols before
distribution all right so let me ask
representative plane and representative
murray
who are familiar with the details of a
amendment they would like us to consider
in addition to the other ones that we
have
this chair will need to recess this
committee
from 1 to 1 30. we will need to go in
recess
so my question is do you want to try
and come back before that at noon
or for your past or would you prefer
to simply recess until 30.
so do you think that something can be
worked on by 12 12 15.
all right we'll be back let's try to
reconvene at 12 o'clock
i want to try to accommodate members who
at 1 30 i understand somebody's going to
have to leave
so we'll let's come convene at um
12 o'clock and 12 15
we'll be back at 12 15. recessed until
chairman we are unmuted and our video
amendments are right is
all right great representative good work
all right so uh welcome back to the
election law committee we
took a little longer than um we had
hoped on great but it allowed me to
finish my entire diet
and we just got some paper copies of the
amendment delivered to us so
you committee members should have also
received it online
that we will be considering later this
morning we have
two or this afternoon we have two bills
to be considered actually two in sb43
before i address those bills does
anybody else
does anybody have a motion um that they
would like to bring that is not
related to sb2 or sp3 representative
quayle
yes thank you madam chairman i would
like i'm going to
make the motion to reconsider hp 140
is there a second i'll second it
senator and second set representative
clearly
uh you were on the prevailing side on
okay i'm moving to reconsider because
upon further
thought about the bill while there are
aspects of it
that at the time caused me to think it
should be itl there are
other aspects that i think are worthy of
further consideration
uh specifically uh elements related to
cleaning up
the absentee ballot uh application forms
it's always a good thing to make forms
of the voters
more clear to them thank you the motion
on the floor is to reconsider our vote
on php 154
to vote was actually to itl is there any
further discussion
yes ma'am i would agree with the
representative who spoke prior
and and i will support the motion thank
you thank you representative cody
anybody else
seeing uh no further discussion i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald yeah
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative erosion yes
representative perry yes
representative growing yes yes
clerk is yes representative cody yes
representative ward yes represent
representative murray yes
representative sandler yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes representative
freitas
yes representative hamlet
yes representative moorhead yes
madam chair yes 20 to 0.
uh h.314 is open for further motion by
this committee representative clearly
without a motion yes thank you very
chairman i move
that the committee retained a speed on
4.
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you madam chairman
for the reasons that this stated i think
the bill is
i think it's worth preserving the
opportunity to give it further
consideration
some elements thank you any further
discussion
on the motion on the floor which is to
retain hp 144.
that number one
four four it was a vote we took on
monday
that we are reconsidering i'm chairman
who's the primary sponsor on 144
representative bergeron is the primary
sponsor
thank you
not seeing any further discussion i will
call ask the clerk
off roll representative mcdonald
yeah representative home o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative yes representative
barry yes
representative growing yes represent
yes clerk yes representative cody
yes ward yes
representative bergeron um murray
yes representative lane
yes representative freitas
yes representative hamlet
yes representative muirhead
yes madam chair yes
i think you skipped me representative
heyman
and your vote would be yes
thank you who she said representative
hamer i better checked
if you noticed our clerk was on a much
faster roll today with these names
she just kept going so sure we got it
right the next time
we needed 0 20-0 so without
uh objection this hb 144
will be retained um
the two bills we had on the calendar for
this afternoon
uh let's turn that i announced for this
uh the first one would be sb ii sv2
had a public hearing on january 22nd it
was our first public hearing
it was allowing the pre-processing of
ballots and postponement of the annual
town meetings in the year 2021
where concerns of hogan exist
is there a motion on sb2 i make a motion
madam chair
to retain senate bill two is there
it's been moved and seconded would you
like to speak to your motion
representative
sure so the content
the relevant content of this bill has
been covered
in address with a executive order of the
governors
there may be a chance that at some point
those
assume that those executive orders
become relaxed
the event that they get relaxed prior to
some of the towns that haven't got to
their town elections yet
this we could pass this to give them
relief
in the event that the executive order
stay in places isn't needed anyway
and in the final analysis the
bill will drop dead after 2021 anyway so
i think it's a good back stop to retain
it in case it's needed hence the motion
is there any further discussion on the
motion on the board which is to retain
sb2
i've seen no discussion so i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald yeah
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative
yes representative perry yes
representative brown
yes representative quailey yes clerk is
yes representative cody yes
representative ward yes representative
murray
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer
yes representative lane
yes representative freitas
hamlet yes yes thank you
uh the final bill before this committee
for consideration today is
sb 43 just built at a public hearing on
march
5th it is an act after authorizing an
audit of the rockingham county district
7 elections
we've had a large public hearing we've
seen a lot
of a few at least amendments officially
processed by ols some like
some by email is there a motion
representative yes madam chair thank you
i would move that this committee adopt
what is amendment 2021 hyphen
0 7 72 h to senate bill 43
[Music]
would you like to speak to your
amendment yes amendment just
uh the amendment is approximately the
same
length as the first bill and it starts i
will say by amending the bill
and it is a complete replacement thank
you representative
thank you point of order yes
could you please repeat the the number
of the amendment
2021 0 7
7 2. thank you
i don't know whether you can find
anything in your email at this point but
thank you madam chairman i'd like to
introduce
amendment 772 h to senate bill 43.
this amendment replaces the entire bill
and is based on the people of windham
and the people throughout the state and
the testimony heard
last week on senate bill 43
we are most grateful for the time and
thought placed
into this audit it's
clear that senate bill 43 must pass
as questions need to be answered
this amendment again that replaces the
entire bill
carefully adds items suggested by
windham
to perform a forensic election
audit by a forensic
election audit team
to see if the results of the november
3rd
2020 general election results
are in comparison with the recount
the audit authorizes and directs
an audit of the ballot counting machines
their memory cards and hand tabulation
of all ballots the audit process
shall be determined by the forensic
audit election team and at a minimum
the audit process shall include
all ballots run through the machines
used in windham on november 3rd
2020 and a hand
tallying of all ballots
in the windham rockingham district
number seven
state rep race the governor race
and the race for u.s senate
the audit's purpose is to generate a
report
as to whether the machine counting
devices
and memory cards functioned properly on
november 3rd
whether the number of ballots tallied by
hand in windham
on election night and those tallied in
the recount is the same as the ballots
cast
whether hand tabulation procedures
followed by windham and the secretary of
state
during the recount contributed to
variances
and include recommendations for
improvement
to machine and hand processing
the location of the audit would be a
location other than
windom and other than
a customary place that the secretary of
state
would hold a recount
the audit shall be live streamed and
recorded
public access is determined of course by
safety precautions by the fire marshal
and in equal numbers
of three groups windham designees
selected by the town of windham
designees by the secretary of state and
attorney
general offices and members of the
public
i'd be careful to note that there are
certain
companies and individuals not allowed to
the audit
one of which is lhs associates
it was responsible for
the sales and services of the ballot
counting
devices
windham is responsible for transporting
the machines
the secretary of state and the ag's
offices for transporting ballots to and
from
the audit location and for security
the audit shall be completed within 45
days of
passage
there will be a forensic report
due to the secretary of state to the
town of windham
to the ballot law commission within 45
days
of the audit completion
additionally reports of the
secretary of state and attorney general
offices
to the speaker of the house the
president of the senate
and the board of selectmen at windham
as well as a report of the ballot law
commission
to be issued the secretary of state
and the attorney general shall have the
authority
to unseal the ballot boxes for the
purposes of the audit
the forensic audit the audit shall not
alter
official results of the house of
representative race
and the secretary of state attorney
general's office
and the town of windham shall provide
whatever information or documentation
is needed by the forensic election
audit team to conduct this forensic
audit and this amendment
would make the bill effective upon its
passage
and so with that review of amendment
number
772 h to senate bill 43
taking into very careful consideration
all of the testimony feedback and
written suggestions for this forensic
audit with that i will conclude my
remarks and urge all of my colleagues
on this very important bill for windham
for new hampshire to vote ought to pass
thank you representative any questions
for representative any discussion on
representative mooney has this matter
been caught
um reviewed by windham officials i
noticed that window
officials are on this minute yes this
amendment has we've been in
communication with the windham
delegation
and they have seen this amendment all
right
um i have a question on the amendment
um page 2
i think that the decision excuse me
that you know we're going to have
a you know if we have this at a
sufficient place big enough to do this
and provide security
that members of the public and certainly
officials are going to want to be there
um but i
would prefer in legislation that we
don't get into the nitty-gritty
i would rather leave the nitty-gritty to
the officials which would include people
like the fire marshal
and whatever they decide so
when we talk about who might attend it
seems to me
that if the town of windham
wants to have their moderator in
attendance
the forensic audit team is going to make
sure that the moderator doesn't have
anything to do with it but
it would allow that person to be i don't
if windham wants that person to be
present i don't see
an issue with that um and
i know that wyndham officials when they
looked at it
would want to be able to have some say
and there are certainly people who have
been
active and i and i feel that
election officials involved in the
recount would include the secretary of
state and
probably the deputy secretary who you
were asking to
designate people but they would not be
able to attend
um and i understand that there were
concerns about
lhs associates being there i would think
that they would want to take advantage
of the live stream anyways
and i don't know that women would want
them there but maybe somebody from the
forensic auditing just wants them there
and windham would need to use one of
their designees
um so i raised that issue
for i see that representative mooney
representative mcdonald representative
bergeron and representative lane
are on this amendment um and i'm
wondering whether
and i know that windham does have
concerns
that windham be allowed to designate and
i
end so i'm wondering whether the
sponsors
would agree that this amendment i think
was a terrific amendment and i want to
thank everybody for doing the work
but i would like it contingent on lines
12 through 17
not being a part of the amendment
because i think
we need to consider some liberties in
regards to
an attempt and if and if there's only
enough space for six people at that
point it's not going to be much of an
issue anyways
so i throw that out there for discussion
representative brown uh i would
i think the intent madam chair of this
is that the people in
these especially the first two not be
involved
in the process i agree with you that
c would also involve the i believe would
involve the secretary of state and the
deputy secretary of state
but if if we if the sentence previous to
that
read to avoid the appearance of
propriety
uh none of the following groups shall be
involved
in the audit process that would that
would allow them to attend but not be
representative o'brien
i believe mr trojan have a question
first
oh i'm sorry representative thank you
madam chair could could i ask um
representative pony a question in regard
to this
so what was the intent of this uh
representative on part c
part c the election officials yeah
that was based on uh feedback received
i would be amenable to
removing that i would be amenable to
removing
b however
i would ask that a
be remaining in the bill
yeah all right i think i'm okay with
that representative summer brian
thank you ma'am uh my suggestion
for at least a for something for to
think about
for the other ask for b may be that
such persons are available but not
in an active role so they're available
if consultation is necessary
and they're they're there but they are
not taking an active role well i guess i
come back to you and that's micromanaged
too much
sorry um that's why i sort of wanted to
leave it to
the three people that three groups that
have the biggest interest
in that in this as sort of selecting who
is there windham and the secretary of
state's office
so representative sweeney with a motion
to amend the amendment be in order
we will i will entertain that subject to
moving an amendment on the amendment for
the amendment let's see
if there's anybody else who wants to
make a comment representative lane
please thank you
thank you madam chair i think you the
language was added as representative
mooney
indicated to address some of the
concerns that were raised by the town of
wyndham and that
pop that show up in uh amendment 6
3 8 h um i i think it was to avoid
impropriety
so that people trusted that there would
not be the people who actually conducted
the recount and conducted the hand count
the night of the election
were not directly involved and i think
that's where their concern came from
but if we can address that and we feel
comfortable by taking it out that the
process
will be will be you know transparent i
think that was what they were trying to
get at
just to answer some of the questions
that came up and if we delete them
i guess my question is are we
comfortable that that addresses the
transparency issue that was raised
well i think the transparency issue was
raised by windham so to that extent they
need to pick the right people there that
they want to have there
if they're concerned about it i
why should i be deciding that for for
window
and the same thing for the secretary of
state's office if they're concerned
about the secretary of state's and ag's
office is concerned about the appearance
of impropriety
and they should be um i think once we
start picking who we
think creates an appearance of
impropriety i think we have lots of
other people who might think appearances
have been propriety or raised by other
people that
don't require us um and
and to the extent lh s and i i'm not
i'm sort of willing to go to the map on
b and c coming out
i'm not so stuck on a because i think
lhs can view it live streamed or
be a part of it and the forensic audit
team in my opinion should have the
ability to access anybody they want
so if it turns out would this mean that
as part of the forensic audit team they
wanted to ask the moderator and window
something that went on
i'm afraid that this would we're
picturing the actual process being in a
room and people being there
just prohibit them from contacting them
as part
of the audit process and i think we need
to be careful about that because i think
it would potentially prevent them from
even contacting
lhs associates in regards to the machine
parts of the machine
so i think the burden of impropriety is
out of
our hands and it should be given to the
people who have the most
interest in infatuating a good outcome
of this
audit representative sweeney did you
have a question
representative thank you madam chair
i personally don't have a problem with
the language the way it is i understand
what you're saying
um to me
it is it is very important in light of
what's happened
in light of the feedback we've done in
this to avoid the
appearance of impropriety um
the ad language interview itself doesn't
limit from what i can tell
the ability for the forensic experts to
consult
with all three of those people on the
matter
and it doesn't prevent them from from
picking anybody else any other
entities that they need to i think it's
it adds
a little stronger language to the fact
that we take
impropriety seriously and
it makes it a little cleaner in my mind
and you know i'm not
opposed to taking vnc but i i don't
really have a problem with the way it is
i just want to
[Laughter]
making it um representative ward
well i'd just like to say that i would
agree with retaining
all three sections a b and c they seem
we're going to go through this entire
process we might as well
include those restrictions
i need to tell you that i i don't
windham has specifically said that they
are going to want
um people there and you don't get to
pick who you think the other side thinks
it's improper
representative
if we take lines 12-17 out
and if we leave them in there's nothing
to prevent the
producers from consulting whoever they
wish that they need technical
information
process information is that right am i
interpreting this right right
is it separation this is about just
public access
this is about public access and whether
or not wyndham and the secretary of
state
can have whoever they want again
that's really what this is about
and if you've ever been to a recount
there is a significant amount of people
present
at wheathouse and i think it could
eliminate
a fair amount of people as i said the
secretary of state and the deputy
and some of their staff and it would
eliminate the moderator the town clerk
and anybody who touched a ballot in
windom
do we know anything about the seating
arrangements for members of the public
building no you don't know
separated from under the i'm assuming
that the forensic
team will want them separated but that's
why we've got
the selection for members of the public
i would presume that that's why the
member the people on this
left it up to them and um
the forensic audit team is in charge of
the actual
conduct in space i would assume they're
going to want to coordinate the area
that the
audit and the ballots are being touched
you're not going to want anybody in the
area that the ballots are
i mean they have a personal statement
the outcome of this also
and i apologize for raising this issue
but
it's important that frankly
the secretary of the state is allowed to
be present in the building when this
representative o'brien thank you ma'am
it
under section c that members of
of the secretary of state staff that are
well versed in running recounts
and and such would not be they happen to
have been
involved in any way uh on the november
12th
recount they would not be allowed to
be involved in this they would not be
able to be present
at any time based on this language and
follow
a follow-up to is that going to create a
staffing
problem for them to complete this task
i don't know the forensic audit team
would be in charge of who they wanted to
do the test
representative lane yes thank you
uh manager um i i think
we're we're tending to read this in
isolation because we do
have the auditors selected and the
secretary of state
um gets to pick and the a.g pick one
of the members of the team and the town
picks a member and then they
those two pick the third member and they
set up how they're going to do the audit
and who they're going to meet with
and how they're going to do the audit
and who they talk to
if it's creating an issue i guess i'm
not
like you i'm not willing to forego the
whole bill because of these sections i
just
we put it in to honor some of the things
that the town of wyndham had asked for
but i think there are other safeguards
to give them that transparency
so i don't think taking it out
necessarily
eliminates the transparency because the
audit
team has to be transparent about their
methodology
just to reassure everybody i'm not sure
that we this is the only thing that's
giving us transparency
so i guess representative lane is one of
the sponsors on the bill
what is your position on what should we
can or needs to be left in right i mean
i
i guess i'm also a little bit concerned
about a
because if they do want them there if
there's a if there's a glitch with the
machines at the thing do they want
somebody there from that company to try
and explain it not necessarily
to fiddle with the machine but to
explain what's going on
thank you representative lane and i
think that was my position when i saw
the yes my concern when i saw the
distinction that if we're leaving this
to the um audit team we should leave it
representative i think it's i agree
with madam chair i think it's okay to
not have sections b and c or even a b
and c
these are observers in this section and
public access to observing
the audit is what we might say in line
five of page two
and we have public access to observing
the audit so that
so that the process is transparent and
and the people who are chosen
you know are decided by windham
designees designees of the secretary of
state
and ag and members of the public there
are three groups that get to choose who
are observers
and totally different from who's
participating in the process which is
page one
you know line nine and so i think it's
you know fine not to have those i don't
think this
those sections need to be there
discussion
all right representative rowan madam
chair i think
this section by excluding
these groups literally from the building
during the audit would certainly exclude
key people from wyndham from even being
in the building
the way i rated it would exclude the
anybody from the secretary of state's
office who was involved in recount
from being in the building it would
exclude lhs
associates who might be needed to answer
questions of
from the forensic auditors from being in
the building
and i think that this would handcuff
the forensic auditor so i
i would move that we remove starting in
line
10 with to avoid
through line 17 we removed from
this amendment is there a second i will
second that
i'm not seeing any i'm going to ask the
representative mcdonald representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
no
representation no
yes
representative crowing yes
representative quailey yes
clerk says yes representative
[Music]
yes representative
murray yes represent
yes representative murray
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer
yes representative lane
yes representative freitas
yes representative hamblet
so what's currently on the floor is
motion
it is a motion to adopt
minus
lines 10 and a half through 17.
that motion is on the floor
further discussion representative
manager i believe that we
uh further amend the amendment uh by
changing
on the first page line 27
remove the race for governor and replace
it with the race for president and vice
president of the united states
is there a second to that motion i'll
second it
would you like to speak to your motion i
would i think the
the people that are looking for the
window results
i think most people that go to the polls
and we see this time and time again
vote for president and vice president
and then they drop off the vow
um i think by if we do a hand tally of
the ballot's castle in them
for the president and vice president for
the united states senate race
and then the district seven state
representative race will get a more
fully encompassing uh version of the
ballot from the top
very top of the ballot at the
presidential level to the
bottom of the battle of the state
representatives this meeting is in
recess
until 1 35
as the committee is aware the chair had
a commitment beginning
in two minutes um that she cannot miss
and we are in recess until 1 35 thank
you
[Music]
so
okay all right thank you everybody for
indulging me
i had a previous commitment that
required my participation
in a different video conference starting
at 105.
um this committee is reconvened
to continue consideration on sb
43 amendment on the floor
is 2021-07
which has been amended
to delete
lines what i refer to as 10 and a half
through 17.
that motion passed
and there is another motion that's been
made on the floor
by representative sweeney and seconded
by
uh representative ross representative
sweeney
withdraw my motion you've withdrawn your
motion representative barry what's your
position on your second
i will also withdraw my second mountain
view all right
hb2021-0772
with um the lines that i spoke about
deleted um we
have contacted ols in regards to
making that deletion in the hopes we
might actually have
a new amendment number but i don't
believe
you do at this time
i fortunately have not been involved in
that representative
um thank you madam chair not to confuse
things even more
but um one of our
one of my colleagues caught an error i
think
something that should be added on line
five page two
uh towards the end to add the words to
observe after the word numbers so in
other words it would say public access
to the audit
shall be granted in equal mo mem and
equal numbers to observe
as is deemed so i would make the motion
to add those words to observe
is there a second to your motion
representative hamlet
seconds yes i second that
thank you um representative lane
did you want to speak any more to that
motion i don't
think so madam chair it just it's
exactly what we were talking about i
think it kind of came up when we were
talking about the lines 10 and a half
through 17 just to make it clear that
they were observing
so i will just point out that i really
don't want to test this theory that if
you put a couple of lawyers looking at a
document you can never
finalize it well it wasn't me
i it wasn't me it was actually one of
the non-lawyers
all right um there is a motion
on the floor is there any further
discussion on the motion
representative hamlet oh
uh am i immediate yeah no sorry i didn't
i didn't uh lower my hand i would just
seconded the
okay motion you all right seeing no
further discussion i'm kind of going to
call for the role
of the third grade role we are
on a amendment moved by representative
lane
seconded by representative campbell okay
mcdonald yes representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative trojan yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative quality yes mark is
yes
representative cody yes representative
ward
murray thank you representative murray
yes thank you representative sandler
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes represent
freitas
representative our representative
freitas had to leave this afternoon and
i actually think she's she's out there
she was waiting for another invite madam
chair
yeah i don't know if she i don't know if
representative hamlet yes yes
yes madam chair yes
on the floor we have a motion for 20 21
0 7 7 2 as amended by motion to delete
ones 10 and a half through 17
and to add the words to observe
after the words equal numbers on line
five
the motion the motion on
the senate bill as amended is open
on the floor to further amendment
or does anybody have anything else
they'd like to say
original motion which has been amended
two times
all right i'm seeing nothing as far as
hands online
hands electronically ordered
anything in the room unless
representative moody's 10 post is a hand
no
[Music]
as proposed based on our deliberations
thank you all right so
clark could call the role we'll we'll go
we'll spend a little time afterwards
yeah okay representative mcdonald
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative yes representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative quali
yes clerk yes representative cody
yes
ward yes representative murray
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes representative
freitas
yes representative hamlet
yes representative your head yes
adam cheer yes 22-0
on the floor before the house election
law committee is
sb 43 as amended by the committee
i will leave it to ols to decide how to
describe it as it apply
as it arrived with the words sb 43 as
amended by the senate
what is on the floor now is sp 43
as amended by this house committee
is there any further discussion on the
motion
in the room or electronically so i will
call ask the clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald yeah
representative putin o'brien
yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes representative
yes representative perry yes
representative growing
yes representative yes
yes representative cody yes
representative murray
yes representative sandler
yes
yes yeah representative ward i think i
skipped over you
uh that you did yes if i saw your
yes representative lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
your head
sb 43 as amended by the senate has
now been amended by this committee
normally i would put this on the consent
calendar i guess i'd watch the consensus
of the committee
as to whether or not you think this will
be full for debate
um in which case i would then ask it to
go
into the regular calendar just because
chairman i i believe this should go on
the consent calendar if um
representatives feel so impassioned
about this they have the option to
remove it as such but i think in the
interest of
moving forward with this process against
does anybody else have any thoughts on
yes ma'am chair i i agree with the
previous speaker and also
i think the people of windham deserve to
have this
expedited as quickly as possible
thank you thank you so without objection
this will go
on the consent calendar does
anybody have any other business to do
before the committee here today
i'm not seeing anything um i will be in
touch with representative cody
as to uh minority opinions
um but we will work on getting
everything
for the calendar so that this committee
can represent to the full body
the work that has been done over the
prior
really less than two months i want to
thank everybody
in this room on screen every member of
this committee
i want to thank representative murray
for being willing to come back a second
day
to get the work done i think this is the
most fields that the election law
committee has
ever dealt with and we had some
unanimous votes so that means something
so i want to i want to thank everybody
and
the next meeting of this committee will
be um
in the calendar and we'll get an email
for you